in this video we're gonna take a look at
how the social contract issues have been
addressed around the world it turns out
there's quite a bit of experience with
this
sometimes with success for a limited
period of time and sometimes without as
much success so let's see how other
countries address these issues let's
start with Australia Australia has a
long history in the 1980s a new prime
minister came along by the name of Bob
Hawke and he came into office
negotiating a new labor agreement called
the accord with the labor movement where
he was saying to labour if you limit
your wage increases to the price
increases that are happening in the
country we will then find some
offsetting things that we can do in
Social Welfare so they negotiated a
national health insurance they
negotiated a national pension program
they put in place a variety of other
worker adjustment programs and for
business they allowed over time much
more flexibility in promoting collective
bargaining at the level of the firm that
worked for quite a while new prime
minister comes in from a different party
says no more of this and so it hasn't
really continued up until today but now
in recent years Australia has taken a
more modern approach it says today's
workforce needs flexibility for more
parental leave so that women and men can
take care of their family and work
responsibilities so in 2011 their first
parental leave program was put in place
at a national level now they're
struggling to make that work and to
fight those who want to repeal it but it
is continuing to play an important role
like Australia Britain has a long
history in the 1960s and 70s like
Australia they were trying to limit wage
increases to deal with inflation and
then in the 1980s along comes Margaret
Thatcher as a new prime minister called
the Iron Lady and she says no more of
that I'm gonna take a hard line she took
on the most powerful union in the
country the miners union in 1984 in 1985
and she basically broke a strike of that
and started to bring down the rate of
wage increase and help companies get
more flexibility and limited labor power
that carried forward up until the
election of another new prime minister
tony blair in the 1990s and tony blair
basically said i'm not going to go back
to the old labor policies but i'm also
not going to continue the Thatcher
approach we're gonna try a third way and
he looked at the workplace issues that
were relevant for his point in time and
he said let's negotiate let's put in
place a commission a labor business
government academic commission to set up
a minimum wage so that we can help those
at the bottom of our income distribution
and that's the most successful part of
his legacy well if you really want to
look at the longest history of labor
management consultation and cooperation
you have to go to continental Europe
countries like Sweden Denmark France
Germany
sometimes Italy and others in Sweden for
example there's a long history of
business labor and government
negotiating in a cooperative way both at
the national levels and more recently at
the local and regional levels and
company levels basically it's all part
of the social democratic values of the
Swedish in the Nordic societies saying
we need to work together to promote
democracy and equity in our economic
policies and so that policy continues
today even in times of difficulty well
take another look at another country
Denmark Denmark in recent years has
recognized the real issue is how do we
adjust from an industrial to a more
dynamic innovation based economy that
means firms need more flexibility to
hire and fire and lay off people as the
economy changes and so Denmark has
traded off what they call flexibility
for security that is firms are more open
and and free to lay people off but
there's an active labor market policy
that then supports workers as they make
the
transition to new jobs with a stronger
safety net with training and with
adjustment insistence so that then helps
firms to maintain their flexibility and
to adapt to changing times so around the
world we see a variety of different
approaches to these issues
Japan is another country with a long
history of labor management consultation
for years its Ministry of International
Trade and Industry worked with business
and labor at the national levels in lots
of consultation to say here is basically
the wage target for increasing wages
this year and then individual companies
and enterprise unions would use that
target to negotiate their specific
conditions and that worked quite well
for Japan and for business and labor in
China in that country for many years but
then as the economy changed and Japan
began to get competition from China and
other places it broke down and now China
is trying to figure out how to get wages
moving more aggressively and prices
increasing because it's having trouble
adapting to a more dynamic economy
another example a very different example
would be in Korea Korea has had a very
tumultuous labor-management history up
until the mid-1980s unions were
suppressed in Korea and there were often
violent strikes that would come and then
get suppressed and the police would come
in and it would be dyed it would all die
down for a while and would be quiet
but then in 1987 the government began to
open up the labor market to stronger
worker rights and it said let's try to
work together but that long history of
conflict made it very very difficult for
labor and management to work together
and so even today we now see big
protests happening in Korean workplaces
as the government tries to get korean
employers to be more flexible and korean
workers are saying we are not sharing in
all of the prosperity of this country
another example would be in China
perhaps there's no country that better
more needs
a new social contract than China as we
all know as the Chinese economy began to
open up to more private enterprise and
foreign investment we saw a wave of
strikes in China first at Honda in 2010
a big strike that resulted in a wage
increase and we've seen that carry over
and strikes at one of Apple's big
suppliers of parts for computers called
Foxconn where not only workers are
striking but sometimes they commit
suicide in protest of the conditions
that they face so China doesn't really
have institutions and policies to govern
workplace negotiations it badly needs to
find a way to allow workers to express
their needs their interests their voice
at the workplace and at the same time
maintain what they call tranquillity in
their relationships but it's very
difficult today perhaps too often we
find that not only are these spontaneous
worker protests occurring but they often
take the plant manager hostage so here's
a picture of an American who has a plant
in China who's actually waving from
inside his office to people on the
outside because the workers are saying
to him you're not paying fair wages we
need to negotiate a better arrangement
so around the world we see these
differences we see in Singapore for
example a much better labor-management
relationship because there the
government takes a strong hand controls
a lot of economic policy but it does so
with what we would call a highroad
strategy it invests in training it
encourages firms to have good
labor-management relations it's
controlled that the the labor movements
so that there aren't as many strikes
this is controversial because it's not
quite the democratic society that we
would want but it's the way in which
they do it in Singapore if we turn to
South America countries have had a more
difficult time there they've had on and
off approaches again often with
dictatorial governments controlling
labor and management
activities but now opening up to more
democracy but having tremendous problems
with price increases and labor protests
and then finally I think we can see some
countries where organisations act on
their own so in Brazil for example some
companies are taking their own approach
to developing a social contract and not
waiting for the government to take
action
well what lessons can we learn from all
of this I think there are two first it
often takes a crisis a crisis will lead
the parties to pull together whether
it's the end of World War two or whether
it's a deep financial crisis in Asia or
some kind of other natural crisis that
might occur perhaps from climate change
or whatever so crisis often helps
parties to set aside their differences
and for a while they can work together
and forge a new set of agreements the
second thing is that it is to remember
that it timing is everything
that one has to take advantage of
specific events and when they occur like
a financial crisis maybe you can
renegotiate pensions in an appropriate
way or you can deal with problems of
recalcitrant unions or recalcitrant
employers and find ways to get them to
work together because there's a specific
issue that they both confront so timing
is everything
using crisis as an opportunity for
change so all around the world workers
employers governments educators need to
figure out when it's possible to
negotiate a new social contract and what
are the issues that are current and
relevant to our times every country in
the world needs to address these issues
because we have serious problems in our
workplaces that need to be addressed and
so we're very interested what are your
thoughts what's most important in your
country what issues should the parties
with your help be addressing we look
forward to getting your thoughts
on this in our discussions